[Music]
foreign
's GI joke that's the focus of tonight's
angle
[Music]
all right lots of big stories out there
getting little coverage by pretend
journalists locked on the Trump
indictment conveniently to the exclusion
of all of Biden's disasters
like the fact that China is building a
powerful spy Post in Cuba just 100 miles
from Miami no big deal
or that would probably lose a war
defending Taiwan against China right now
because we've sent so much of our own
weaponry and our own Munitions to
Ukraine this from Politico the Biden
Administration has been slow to respond
to what's minimally required to prevent
an indo-pacific catastrophe which is the
need to rapidly build a better deterrent
especially new stockpiles of Munitions
that would convince China it could be
too costly to attack Taiwan
but do we even have the capacity to spit
out Munitions to make up for what we've
sent to zielinski a swift response may
not be possible in large part because of
how shrunken the U.S manufacturing base
has become since the Cold War
huh
who warned about that decades ago well
Pap Buchanan that's who and later people
like myself and obviously president
Trump
and remember when he warned about that
what the Pentagon did to him
yet despite these disturbing Tales of
American Military decline the White
House they don't seem
earned
they have other priorities
Lighthouse and happy Pride
that was nice doesn't it okay
I love you guys I'm so happy to be here
I just want to say what an honor and I
know what a big deal it is that I'm here
the largest Pride Celebration The White
House has ever had
[Music]
now the Extravaganza really began in
Earnest the week before where there
wasn't any dancing but the pitch was the
same
it's an honor to represent the
Department of Defense at the 12th Annual
Pride employee Resource Group events
acknowledged the contributions of
service members and Department civilians
and the lesbian gay transgender and
queer Community as a cisgender woman in
the Department of Defense I can
personally attest to the importance of
allies and advocacy the open inclusion
of Americans like me
combat ready transgender volunteers
enhances our Readiness promotes
Innovation and fosters a culture of
respect and understanding that makes the
Armed Forces better
well unfortunately things don't seem to
be getting better in fact they're
getting worse the Army will miss its
recruiting Target this year by a
staggering 25 percent
we are not going to make that goal we
are doing everything we can to get as
close to it as possible but we are going
to fall short of that
now most other branches are in a
recruiting mess as well it's a
full-blown crisis but the Air Force's
answer to this well check out this tweet
that Airman isn't saluting the American
flag but instead is standing in front of
something called the progress pride flag
but will approaches like this help with
enlistment and the deficit there now we
of course love all of our service
members no matter who they are and are
grateful for all of their patriotism and
their service yeah wouldn't it be
irresponsible not to question why our
pentagon is spending so much time
inventing imaginary enemies when we
actually have real ones lgbtq plus and
other diverse communities
are under attack
just because they are different
hate for Hate's sake we must be prepared
to confront any such challenge directly
service members do not die because the
service shows Pride love and rainbows
service members don't die
because they do
Pride saves lives
now this Pentagon supported message is
clear any deviation from their world
view is a serious threat and it will be
dealt with as such and it will be
Stamped Out that includes laws duly
passed by state legislatures to stop the
sexual exploitation and indoctrination
of school children
this is Lieutenant General Deanna Burt
from the space force more than 400
anti-lgbtq plus laws have been
introduced at the state level
that number is rising and demonstrates a
trend that could be dangerous for
service members their families and the
Readiness of the force as a whole
the lieutenant general believes that U.S
Readiness will somehow be improved if
concerned parents including many vets
are branded as haters
and who would those parents want
commanding their sons or daughters in
battle
a man is hostile to their values and
beliefs as Joe Biden we have some
hysterical and I would argue Prejudice
people who are engaged in all what you
see going on around the country it's a
it's an appeal to fear and it's appeal
that is totally thoroughly unjustified
and ugly these are our kids these are
our neighbors it's cruel
now how exactly is this going to work in
practice does he and the other woke
activists in his White House do they not
realize how much the military depends on
the south and the Midwest for its
fighting force
now why does it seem like inclusion only
works one way for these people
not progressives want to do to our
military what they've done to every
other aspect of our culture they want to
poison it
the military was one of the last
bastions of traditionalism left in
America and that fact was in part what
made a career in the service so
attractive to so many
most serve to defend the American way of
life
They don't serve to host drag shows on
military bases
the dod was shamed into having to
announce that it would no longer host
drag shows at U.S military military
installations to celebrate pride month
but don't consider this some big victory
because the only reason those shows were
canceled is because GOP Senators
complained and clearly the top brass has
spooked by all this activism we're all
about ready to sound readers in the
future in modernization I think the
accusations of Walker are grossly over
exaggerated we're we're not a woke Army
we're a ready Army that constant drum
beat that we sometimes hear about a weak
military awoke military is a little bit
of a negative drip drip drip that is
undermining our recruiting at a time
where we really can't afford that
ah so publicizing what they're actually
doing with your tax dollars that's the
problem not the woke Obsession itself
and not certainly not implying that half
the country is bigoted if they disagree
with their new approach
so the time has come for Republicans to
move past nostalgia
and start to have an honest conversation
about what's happened to the US military
What's Happening Now within the ranks of
the military and its leadership
and what's going to happen to our
mission and whether it's going to be
compromised as a result and that's the
angle hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else